les situations exceptionnelles n'est
notamment de la pandémie du covid-19 à
partir du printemps 2020 et de
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie au
mois de février 2022 ont eu des
conséquences socio-économiques qui
marquent aujourd'hui durablement le
quotidien des Français et des Françaises
ce contexte de crise a généré des
équilibres sur les marchés économiques
en forte hausse des prix de matières
premières et des perturbations de la
production dans le même temps certaines
entreprises ont réalisé des profits très
élevés excédant la moyenne de leurs
résultats historique avant la crise du
covid-19 plusieurs voix s'élèvent
aujourd'hui pour taxer c'est super
profits en septembre 2022 lors du
discours de l'état de l'Union la
président de la Commission européenne
elle proposait d'instaurer un
plafonnement des revenus des producteurs
d'électricité infra marginaux et une
contribution de solidarité temporaire
obligatoire ciblant les entreprises
actives dans le secteur du pétrole brut
du gaz fossile du charbon et du
raffinage
ce paquet de mesures a été approuvé le
30 septembre 2022 par les ministres de
l'énergie des États membres toutefois en
plus de ces dispositifs européens il
apparaît nécessaire d'encourager ces
entreprises notamment celle du secteur
énergétique mais aussi les transporteurs
les banques et les assurances à mettre à
profit ces résultats exceptionnels pour
investir notamment pour faire face aux
défis très importants que pose et posera
un moyen terme le changement climatique
à la planète à nos modes de vie mais
aussi de manière plus concrète pour ces
entreprises à leur modèle d'affaires
pour désinciter la distribution de ses
résultats exceptionnels par des super
dividendes et des supers achats
d'actions c'est amendement propose de
mettre en place une majoration
temporaire de 5 points du prélèvement
forfaitaire unique le portant à 35% sur
les distributions de revenus par ses
grandes entreprises qui ont un chiffre
d'affaires de plus d'un milliard d'euros
un milliard deux supérieur de 20% à la
manière à la moyenne pardon des revenus
distribués entre 2017 et 2021
merci je vous signale qu'il y aura du
scrutin public sur le 1257 et sur les
trois amendements
identiques qui suivent le 614 monsieur
Breuillet merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre notre amendement je
dois rendre à César ce qui est à César
c'est l'amendement déposé par Jean-Paul
Mattei qui vient d'être défendu par
notre collègue et qui a été adopté le 12
octobre à l'Assemblée nationale ça
n'était pas la nuit du 4 août mais bien
une volonté de justice sociale dans une
période de crise de chercher des
réponses les plus adaptées nous voulons
évidemment reprendre cet amendement qui
a fini dans les poubelles ministérielles
à l'occasion du 49.3 et je voudrais
juste souligner que rendre à César ce
qui est à César c'est une expression
tirée des évangiles synoptiques elle est
une réponse positive à la question posée
par des pharisiens faut-il payer l'impôt
nous répondons oui
merci le 682 monsieur Cosic
c'est le même abondement que mon
collègue broyé donc on la proposition
est de reprendre l'amendement voté
voté à l'Assemblée nationale à
l'initiative du groupe moderne avant
d'être passé sous les fourches codines
de l'article 49-3 par le gouvernement
par contre le groupe socialiste souhaite
que le que le que le Sénas prononce sur
ce dispositif
c'est une mesure de justice sociale et
je crois qu'il est important aussi que
chacun participe à l'effort national
merci
monsieur bouquet oui merci Madame
prudence c'est amis amendement qui
constitue pour nous un repli total un
infime geste mais constituerait en
revanche pour le Sénat et le
gouvernement a dit je vous ai compris le
dispositif un peu alambiqué finalement
simple l'imposition des bénéficiaires de
dividendes des majorités et majoré
pardon de 5 points au titre du
prélèvement forfaitaire unique voyez un
peu l'effort que nous faisons nous
voulons abroger le pfu et revenir à un
régime d'imposition équivalent entre le
capital et le travail nous voulons
dissuader les entreprises qui versent là
nous reprenons cette proposition de la
majorité relative à l'Assemblée
nationale le MoDem qui vise à augmenter
de 5%, l'imposition des personnes
physiques qui reçoit des dividendes même
pas tous les dividendes seulement ceux
des grandes entreprises seulement ceux
des grands entreprises qui versent plus
de 20% de dividendes une année par
rapport à la moyenne des 5 années
précédentes seulement pour les personnes
qui reçoivent plus de 50000 euros de
dividendes sur une année
ce n'est pas ce n'est plus un pas que
l'on fait vers vous ça relève du saut en
longueur malgré toutes ces restrictions
et la mesure que l'on connaît de
l'auteur de cet amendement monsieur
Jean-Paul Mattei quand il s'agit de
taxer le capital la proposition adoptée
à l'Assemblée nationale par tous les
bancs a été enterré malheureusement par
le 49-3 il faut s'arrêter sur la raison
qui préside à la disparition de
l'amendement j'ai mené l'enquête j'ai
écouté RMC vous voyez ce qu'il m'en
coûte Bruno Le Maire estime que cette
mesure est profondément injuste pourquoi
je cite elle touche les personnes
physiques par exemple un salarié qui a
des actions je n'en connais pas beaucoup
et pas les personnes morales comme les
entreprises et le holding monsieur le
ministre combien de salariés touchent
plus 50 000 euros de dividendes sur une
année pas ceux que je côtoie monsieur le
ministre ne vous proposons deux
dispositifs l'un qui concerne un
rubrique qui verse l'autre les
particuliers qui reçoivent comme vous
l'avez fait pour 97 amendements de la
majorité sur les 117 retenus choisissez
ce que vous préférez
merci la vie de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur général
des avis défavorables il y a
comment dirais-je une différence de
seuil sur la question de l'imposition
sur les super dividendes puisque dans un
cas c'est à partir de 750 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires et dans
l'autre cas c'est un milliard deux
c'est un mécanisme chacun l'a bien
compris qui conduit à imposer davantage
les détenteurs de participation dans des
entreprises qui distribuent des
dividendes qui sont 20% supérieur à la
moyenne sur 2017
2021 tout a été dit la question qui se
pose aujourd'hui c'est comment trouver
une juste place dans le fonctionnement
de notre économie sachant qu'en plus
dans cette période puisque c'est
2017-2021 ça a aussi correspondu à une
partie de la période de référence je dis
bien une partie pendant laquelle il y
avait la crise sanitaire avec des aides
publiques de l'État et la question qui
qui nous est posée c'est où on place le
curseur entre le financement par le
marché par les entreprises leur permet
de se développer avec un système
bancaire à côté et où la manière d'avoir
n'ont pas une économie administrée mais
une économie avec une forme de tutelle
je pense que nous devons être
attentif à cette manière de du de voir
notre économie fonctionnait dans ces
périodes de crise comme en période
normale ce sont les éléments qui m'ont
conduit à rendre un avis défavorable
merci la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs nous abordons
une série d'amendements qui touche à la
contribution la juste contribution de
chacune et de chacun dans le cadre de la
crise que nous traversons en réalité
nous avons d'ores et déjà commencé à
aborder ce sujet un peu sans le dire
puisque l'article 4 non yes qui a été
adopté sans intervention et le premier
volet de la transcription dans ce dans
cette loi de finance du mécanisme
européen que nous avons mis en place
pour capter les super profits dans le
secteur de l'énergie le 4e c'est la
partie qui concerne les énergies
fossiles et donc qui se retrouvent dans
ce texte je le mentionne puisque je me
souviens que cet été dans le précédent
PLFR nous avions eu ce débat sur la
question des super profits pas encore
des super dividendes on avait avec Bruno
Le Maire renvoyer vers une discussion
européenne et à l'époque certains nous
avaient accusé de le faire de manière un
peu dilatoire pour gagner du temps pour
enjamber le texte en nous disant qu'il
n'en ressortirait rien bah finalement il
en de sortie une taxe un mécanisme
européen un mécanisme européen qui nous
permet et c'est dans le texte initial de
récupérer 7 milliards d'euros de super
profils appelleront certains en tout cas
de rente inframarginal l'appelleront
d'autres de profits indus en tout cas
immédiatement lié à l'inflation sur les
prix de l'énergie et dans les
amendements du Gouvernement que je
présenterai on propose même d'aller plus
loin et de renforcer ce mécanisme ce qui
permettrait de passer son rendement de 7
milliards à 11 milliards d'euros 11
milliards d'euros de super profits
capter dans le secteur de l'énergie
l'amendement qui est repris ici et
l'amendement effectivement qui avait été
porté par Jean-Paul Mattei à l'Assemblée
nationale cela a été rappelé et nous
avions donné un avis défavorable à cet
amendement pour plusieurs raisons
la première raison c'est que le pfu le
prélèvement forfaitaire unique est une
réussite et un succès on a eu ce débat
plutôt dans la discussion de ce texte et
le rapporteur général avait rappelé
notamment les études qui montrent que la
réforme du prélèvement forfaitaire
unique est autofinancé l'État ne sait
pas appauvri en recette en faisant la
flat taxe ou prélèvement forfaitaire
unique tout simplement parce que le
choix de baisser cette fiscalité sur le
capital c'était justement de renforcer
l'attractivité économique de notre pays
pour qui est davantage d'activités
économiques et que la base taxable
s'élargissent parce que l'activité
s'élargissait et c'est précisément ce
qui s'est passé ce qui s'est passé c'est
que le taux a baissé mais qui le taxe
une assiette qui s'est élargi
précisément parce que la cohérence de
l'ensemble de nos réformes fiscales ça a
été de refaire de la France le pays le
plus attractif d'Europe pour les
investissements étrangers c'est le cas
depuis trois ans c'est le baromètre ewaï
qui le dit ce n'est pas le gouvernement
parce que ça a permis de développer
l'activité économique dans notre pays de
la même manière que depuis qu'on a passé
l'impôt sur les sociétés de 33% à 25%,
on collecte plus d'impôts sur les
sociétés avec le taux à 25%, qu'à
l'époque où il était à 33% on est en
train de faire la démonstration que ça
rapporte plus de taxer moins un gâteau
qui grossit parce qu'on le taxe moins
plutôt que de taxer davantage un gâteau
qui serait précis parce qu'à force de le
surtaxé finalement on fait partir les
gens l'activité et donc il se rétrécit
donc je pense qu'il faut être prudent
quand on propose de revenir sur cette
réforme fiscale même pour un moment
temporaire comme c'est proposé par
certains d'autant plus que et c'est mon
deuxième argument vous dites que c'est
une contribution temporaire et donc dans
ces conditions rien n'empêcherait une
entreprise d'attendre avant de verser
des dividendes que la taxe et que la
contribution temporaire soit passée et
de garder les fonds et d'attendre que le
mécanisme de contribution soit passé
pour verser ses dividendes une fois que
le taux est redevenu est revenu à 30%.
donc je suis même pas certain de
l'effectivité de la mesure que vous
la troisième raison pour laquelle je
suis opposé à ces amendements c'est
parce qu'il porte pour moi un vrai
problème juridique et qu'il serait
probablement censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel pour une rupture
d'égalité devant l'impôt puisqu'ils font
ces amendements ils font varier le taux
d'imposition des actionnaires donc on
parle de personnes physiques selon la
taille la taille de l'entreprise dont
ils sont actionnaires
c'est à dire que prendre deux
actionnaires deux personnes physiques
qui reçoivent des dividendes vous mettez
des taux d'imposition différents selon
la taille de l'entreprise ça serait très
vraisemblablement qualifié comme une
rupture d'égalité devant l'impôt donc
pour cette raison juridique ça ne
fonctionne pas et puis enfin le dernier
point et ça effectivement été mentionné
c'est que nous ce que nous voulons aussi
c'est développer l'actionnariat salarié
au fond on peut se dire que l'objectif
c'est de taxer davantage les
actionnaires mais effectivement on peut
aussi se dire que l'objectif et en tout
cas c'est le nôtre c'est qu'il y ait
plus d'actionnaires dans l'entreprise et
oui c'est possible monsieur bocad
d'ailleurs ça a commencé à se développer
l'actionnariat salarié je crois que
c'est total c'est un chiffre que j'avais
vu passer il y a maintenant entre 12 et
15% de salariés qui sont actionnaires de
leur entreprise alors par définition les
plafonds de dividendes versés sur
l'année sont différents selon les
amendements mais on peut se retrouver
avec des salariés actionnaires de leur
entreprise et il y en a maintenant à
tous les niveaux dans l'entreprise à
tous les niveaux de rémunération qui se
retrouveraient taxés par cet amendement
nous on veut développer l'actionnariat
salarié Bruno Le Maire l'a dit on veut
porter une réforme sur ce sujet en 2023
pour que quand il y a des versements de
dividendes à des actionnaires dans
l'entreprise les salariés puissent être
intéressés également via des mécanismes
d'intéressement de participation ou
d'actionnariats salariés pour toute
réception je pense que ce serait à la
fois un mauvais message en termes
d'attractivité pour notre place
économique et on a vu les résultats
quand même de premiers résultats en tout
cas positif ces dernières années grâce à
la réforme du pfu et de la flat tax ça a
été souligné très largement sur les
bancs dans le débat que nous avons hier
et ensuite pour des raisons encore une
fois profondes juridiques cet amendement
ne fonctionnerait pas et serait très
probablement anticonstitutionnel donc je
vous propose le retrait et sinon je
donne un avis défavorable
merci Monsieur le Ministre j'ai des
explications de votre monsieur Ferro
merci madame la Présidente pour notre
part nous ne sommes pas sectaire et nous
allons voter cet amendement sur la
taxation des super dividendes qu'ils
viennent des centristes du Sénat ou des
centristes de l'Assemblée nationale
puisque nous avons repris leur
amendement et je pense que en effet ce
débat est très important c'est dommage
qu'ils viennent juste avant celui sur
les super profits parce que d'une
certaine manière il y aurait une logique
à ce que nous en parlions à ce que nous
en parlions dans l'autre sens parce que
j'entends les arguments du ministre et
personne ignore que le gouvernement est
très content de la réforme du pfu sur la
taxation du capital mais dans cette
période aujourd'hui je reprendrai les
mots de du président du groupe modem à
l'Assemblée j'assume ma proposition sur
les supers dividendes l'idée de nourrir
le débat sur le rapport entre la
fiscalité du la capitale est celle du
travail et je pense que depuis plusieurs
mois nous avons nous réutilisent débat
d'ailleurs la position du gouvernement
sur les super profits a évolué sous la
pression de l'opinion de nombreux
parlementaires y compris de la majorité
sous celle de l'Union européenne aussi
et le ministre vient de le dire je m'en
réjouis mais il faut aller plus loin et
en particulier sur cette question des
super dividendes parce que si nous
adoptons juste après un amendement de
taxation sur les super profits je dirais
alors très bien mais si nous ne
l'adoptons pas alors les super
dividendes ce sont des supers profits
qui n'ont pas été réinvestis dans
l'entreprise qui n'ont pas servi à
baisser les prix qui n'ont pas servi à
augmenter les salaires des salariés de
l'entreprise donc ce sont des dividendes
qui auraient pu servir à autre chose
comme le réclame le ministre de
l'Économie lui-même et donc les taxés de
manière temporairement supérieure au pfu
c'est vraiment extrêmement logique
merci Monsieur Bocquet oui une question
monsieur le ministre vous dit que vos
choix fiscaux permettent d'encaisser
plus d'impôts sociétés que avant mais là
j'ai le document qui nous a été remis au
mois de septembre le dossier budget et
sur les chiffres annoncés pour les lois
de finances révisées pour le titre de
2022 on était à 59 milliards et vous
prévoyez pour le PLF 2023
55,2 milliards comment expliquer vous
cette différence et puis désolé je vais
ré-infliger à mes collègues la lecture
de ces cours du jeudi dernier mais
Monsieur le Ministre n'était pas là
c'est Monsieur Lescure votre collègue
qui le qui vous précédait juste une
citation pour vous dire que les
actionnaires peuvent remercier les
compagnies pétrolières et les prix
élevés du baril d'or noir sur le seul
troisième trimestre 2022 c'est la
dernière on distribué 46,4 milliards de
dollars de dividendes soit 75% de plus
qu'en 2021 comment voulez-vous que le
débat soit enterré
merci Monsieur le casteur capocanella
merci madame
de l'argument sur la rupture d'égalité
classiquement en matière fiscale il y a
souvent des seuils et là vous nous dites
il y a un seuil donc ça crée une rupture
d'égalité
c'est quand même étonnant merci monsieur
je tenais à remercier le ministre de son
souci de préserver les salariés
franchement dire qu'on va interdire une
surtaxe temporaire sur les dividendes
pour protéger les salariés j'avoue que
c'est un argument qui je pense fera
Flores et sera repris assez largement
mais je voulais aussi dire que dans
cette enceinte j'entends toujours
défendre la valeur travail et bien voilà
qu'on propose de taxer que le groupe du
centriste propose de taxer les
dividendes au même niveau que le travail
franchement si on défend la valeur
travail je trouve pas scandaleux contact
les dividendes à la même hauteur contact
travail
merci alors je oui madame rakmadou
je voulais rajouter aussi que on parle
de taxation mais en fait ils peuvent
éviter cette taxation
si réinvestissent en fait dans
l'entreprise ou auprès des salaires des
salariés donc c'est vertueux merci
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente je vous
confirme monsieur combien
je vous confirme monsieur Bocquet que en
2017 à l'époque où le taux d'impôt sur
les sociétés était encore à 33% ont
collectait 41 milliards d'euros d'impôt
sur les sociétés et que cette année en
2022 au moment où il est descendu à 25%
nous collectons nos collectons 59
milliards d'euros
l'an prochain on verra l'an prochain on
fait des prévisions on fait des
prévisions forcément avec un taux de
croissance qui est moins important
l'année prochaine dans les prévisions
que cette année forcément c'est un
impact mais en tout cas on a passé de
33% à 25% et on collecte beaucoup plus
c'est un fait dans les recettes et je
pense qu'on peut tous s'en réduire ça
montre que l'activité c'est développer
monsieur capo canelas c'est pas un
problème de seuil il y a pas de problème
c'est le fait qu'il y a un seuil de RFR
pour être concerné c'est pas ça le
problème le problème c'est que un même
euro de dividende un même euro selon
qu'ils viennent d'une grande entreprise
qui a fait des supers profits ou d'une
petite entreprise qui n'a pas fait de
super profit se retrouve taxé avec des
taux différents c'est ça le problème de
rupture d'égalité
et donc pour ces raisons là ce serait
très probablement il y a pas d'autres
exemples il y a pas d'autres exemples je
me tournais vers mon équipe dans la
législation fiscale aujourd'hui de
mécanismes comparable et donc ça serait
très probablement jugé inconstitutionnel
pour une raison de rupture d'égalité
devant l'impôt
merci alors je vais mettre aux voix donc
j'ai été saisi oui monsieur le président
oui
moi je vous écoute monsieur le ministre
il y a des points qui me vont pas alors
un premier point qui me va pas
c'est l'idée de dire nous avons fait la
baisse de l'impôt de 25%
sa date d'une autre époque vous étiez
d'ailleurs impliqué dans cette époque là
d'ailleurs autrement mais moi je me
souviens d'avoir voté et d'être d'avoir
été un accord avec la baisse des impôts
à 25%. ça a été fait sous-landes et oui
impôt sur les sociétés c'est à dire la
trajectoire évidemment
ça a commencé
ça a commencé et vous même vous l'avez
fait sur plusieurs années donc il aurait
fallu que Hollande reste au pouvoir et
cet effet donc si vous voulez
donc si vous voulez voilà il n'y a pas
ceux qui et ceux qui ne pas voilà c'est
pas c'est je pense qu'il y avait à
l'époque
comment dire une vision assez large pour
qu'effectivement
il y est on ramène le taux d'imposition
des sociétés au taux moyen européen et
cela a été fait et vous l'avez poursuivi
il n'y a pas de problème là-dessus que
ça produise plus de figurez-vous que je
crois même l'avoir dit à l'époque je
vous le dis très gentiment j'avais dit
il y a pas de lien direct entre le taux
et le produit bon donc contact il y a
pas de difficulté là-dessus donc
deuxième sujet c'est cette notion que
votre politique fiscale aurait fait de
vous le les rois de l'investissement
étranger en France mais ça fait bien 15
ans je sais plus combien qu'on est
premier que on est la première terre
d'investissement étranger en France
voilà et il y a 15 ans on l'était on est
passé second on revient premier bon
enfin on a toujours été parmi les
territoires parmi les territoires
principaux de réception des
investissements donc je voudrais pas
quand même que vous disiez voilà en 2017
il y avait le monde d'avant et puis il y
a le monde d'après voilà et tout d'un
coup tout est magnifique non ça fait
longtemps que c'est le cas et si c'est
le cas c'est d'ailleurs pour un ensemble
de phénomènes la géographie de la France
les compétences etc et aussi les parties
fiscales mais à l'époque fiscalement
c'était pas très attractif et pour
autant les investissements se faisaient
en France je voudrais là-dessus un peu
de prudence dans ces évocations enfin ne
pas confondre quand même ce qui relève
de la taxation des normes des
entreprises et ce qui relève d'un
événement qui viennent se passer qui est
un événement exceptionnel et sur lequel
on peut avoir un système exceptionnel
et moi d'ailleurs je préfère le mot de
contribution exceptionnelle au bout de
taxation vous voyez taxation ça me
fatigue contribution exceptionnelle pour
cette année voilà il y a un besoin et il
y a il me semble une compréhension des
Français aussi sur ce sujet et même je
pense que l'échelle d'entreprise quelque
part bon ils comprennent le sujet quand
même parce qu'ils sont aussi français
ils sont aussi voilà ils savent qu'ils
ont des problèmes dans ce pays et qu'il
faut les résoudre et être solidaire de
cela merci merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement à la fin du quinquennat de
François Hollande dans la loi de
finances pour 2017
mont du départ une trajectoire est votée
non pas pour amener l'impôt sur les
sociétés à 25% mais à 28%. 28% sur 3 ans
et ensuite c'est le gouvernement
d'Emmanuel Macron la majorité qui non
seulement a mis en oeuvre parce qu'il
faut aussi ensuite c'est comme les
décisions qui avaient été prises mais
c'est comme certaines décisions
salariales dans la fonction publique qui
avait été prise quelques mois ou
quelques semaines avant l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 sans être
financée ensuite il faut s'occuper de
financer les choses qui ont été
annoncées ou qui ont été votées et qui a
amené la trajectoire jusqu'à 25% ce qui
n'était pas prévu dans ce qui avait été
voté en 2016 ensuite monsieur le
Président vous m'aurez entendu je crois
ou alors je pense que sa Figuera au
compte-rendu dire tout à l'heure non pas
que la France était devenue le pays le
plus attractif en Europe pour les
investissements étrangers mais redevenu
je ne méconnais absolument pas que notre
pays a une grande attractivité
historique et structurelle évidemment ce
que je constate simplement c'est que ça
faisait quand même un moment qu'ils
n'avait pas eu plus d'usines qui
ouvraient en France que d'usine qui
permet plus d'emplois industriels créés
que détruit encore une fois il s'agit
pas de dire que tout va bien de notre
pays que tout est parfait que tout va
bien dans le meilleur des mondes et que
tout est grâce au gouvernement je dis
juste simplement quand il y a des choses
qui fonctionnent ou qui a des signaux
positifs évidemment que on peut tous
s'en réjouir collectivement pour notre
pays et pour les Français et je pense
que il y a des signaux positifs il y a
des points positifs qui ne tombent pas
du ciel mais qui sont probablement le
fruit d'une politique cohérente qui a
peut-être démarré juste avant l'arrivée
du président de la République par
ailleurs il était dans les murs ou pas
très loin à juste avant aussi pour
porter et défendre ses réformes à
l'époque mais en tout cas qui a été
poursuivi vous avez rappelé qu'il
s'agissait d'une proposition d'un
mécanisme exceptionnel mais moi je redis
dire qu'on met en place une surtaxation
exceptionnelle sur une année je veux
dire vous mettez à la place d'une
entreprise vous pouvez avoir des
entreprises qui vont dire mais on va pas
verser de dividendes cette année là
puisqu'il y a une surtaxation cette
année-là on va attendre l'année suivante
pour renverser quand le taux sera revenu
à 30%. donc pour moi ça rend même
presque inopérant le dispositif et enfin
vous avez dit vous préférez le mot
contribution au motaxe et donc je me
réjouis d'avance que vous souteniez
encouragé les deux contributions portées
dans ce PLF qui sont issus du mécanisme
européen contribution de solidarité
contribution sur les énergéticiens c'est
11 milliards d'euros que nous allons
récupérer à ce titre merci Monsieur
bachel et après je mets aux voix
la Président je me suis mis mes chers
collègues bon on fait un peu de
philosophie mais on va pas faire des
choses opérantes
pourquoi vous savez les entreprises ça
pilote son bilan une grande entreprise
donc vous vous dégagez autant de
dividendes que vous voulez vous pouvez
même racheter vos actions vous savez
pour pas verser des dividendes et ils le
font et ça votre truc sera totalement
inopérant une grande entreprise ça
pilote son bilan si vous faites une
contribution exceptionnelle alors sauf
si évidemment ça dure autant que les
contributions l'exceptionnalité mais non
donc là on fait un peu des groupes mais
en tout cas ce sera pas opérant on peut
le regretter on peut dire que
philosophiquement on est pour les contre
et c'est le débat que nous essayons
d'avoir et c'est tout à fait normal mais
en réalité ce que nous faisons là c'est
juste un peu de théâtre merci donc j'ai
été saisie d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe socialiste sur
l'amendement 1257 je vous rappelle que
l'avis de la commission est défavorable
la vie du Gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement et le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin nombre de votants
343 exprimé 331 pour 150 contre 181 il
n'est pas adopté
j'ai été saisie d'une demande de scrutin
public par les groupes socialistes et
CRCE sur les amendements identiques 614
682 81107 je vous rappelle que la Villa
commission est défavorable la vie du
Gouvernement est défavorable il va être
procédé au scrutin public d'un
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert le
scrutin est clos
du scrutin nombre de votants 343 exprimé
332 pour 150 contre 182 le Sénat n'a pas
adopté
alors cinq amendements faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune et tout d'abord
le 856 monsieur Bocquet monsieur Baki
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre la précision et la clarté sont
les maîtres mots d'une fiscalité juste
et appropriée cette proposition
s'inscrit dans cette droite ligne une
taxe sur toutes les entreprises de plus
de 100 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires qui réalisent des profits
supplémentaires à la moyenne des trois
résultats d'avant parmi un taux
différencier est appliqué selon le
montant de ces super profits les super
profits se font trop souvent au
détriment des travailleurs au détriment
des sous-traitants des consommateurs
mais aussi souvent des investissements
le seul CAC 40 38 entreprises réalise 73
milliards d'euros de bénéfices au
premier semestre + 24 % sur un an Bruno
Le Maire se dit fier nous nous sommes
résolus résolus pour le soutien à nos
compatriotes qui ne comprennent plus à
quoi sert l'état résolu pour les
finances publiques résolues pour les
travailleurs qui créent la valeur mais
n'en retire pas les fruits résolus de
faire contribuer ce qui le peuvent en
somme de chacun selon ses moyens à
chacun selon ses besoins cet été ce
n'était pas le moment nous en débattons
plus tard circulez il y a rien à voir
quelques mois plus tard ou plutôt il n'y
a rien à trouver le 49.3 a douché tout
espoir à l'Assemblée nationale sur la
taxation des profits indus le Sénat a
décidé de débattre malgré ce coup de
force nous ne pouvons plus repousser à
plus tard ce qui correspond à
l'aspiration populaire de justice
fiscale
merci alors deux amendements identiques
le 434 qui le défend monsieur Ferro
merci madame la Présidente donc cet
amendement que je présente au nom du
groupe socialiste et du groupe
écologiste qui l'ont présenté en commun
avec président de la commission des
finances et qui je crois est présentée
de manière identique par nos collègues
communistes il est d'abord la reprise du
dispositif que nous souhaitions
soumettre un réforme d'initiative
partagée dans react de la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel qui estime que
cette disposition fiscale ne relève pas
de l'article 11 de la Constitution mais
cela n'enlève rien à notre demande sur
le fond qui est de pouvoir taxer les
super profits dans cette période
exceptionnelle et je suis tout à fait
d'accord pour l'appeler que pour appeler
contribution exceptionnelle plutôt que
taxation ensuite
nous avons vu juste avant nous n'avons
pas taxé les super dividendes donc
prenons les choses à la source par la
taxation des super profits nous avons
par ailleurs tout à l'heure voter un
régime de taxation inférieure pour je
dirais les mini profits quand nous avons
parlé des TPE PME donc allons-y dans le
sens de la progressivité pour taxer des
super profits dont tout le monde sait
qu'ils sont bien réels même le
gouvernement le reconnaît aujourd'hui il
agit mais uniquement dans un cadre
européen j'ai envie de dire ajoutez-y
aussi une dimension française une
dimension gouvernementale je suis sûr
que vous n'aurez qu'à y gagner en
popularité auprès des Français nous
notre dispositif est bien temporaire il
est bien ciblé sur les très grandes
entreprises il est bien ciblé sur les
super profits et des posts sur les
profils exceptionnels pardon donc il
répond bien à ce qui est aujourd'hui
nécessaire et il permettra aussi de
financer des mesures sociales dont nous
parlons et dont nous savons qu'elles
sont absolument essentiels et il faut
trouver les moyens de les financer merci
Louis 145 monsieur bouquet oui merci on
le voit bien le débat sur les profits
est aujourd'hui partagé sur plusieurs
bancs du Sénat y compris par nos amis
centrices et on salue cette démarche
parce que ça s'appuie sur une attente
populaire très forte qui s'exprime
régulièrement la même volonté qui n'a
pas pu s'exprimer au travers du
référendum d'initiative partagée que
nous avions initiés les uns et les
autres à gauche censurés par le Conseil
constitutionnel cette décision marque
une forme d'interdiction à se prononcer
je crois qu'il est craint par le
gouvernement qui s'était vertu à
défendre auprès du Conseil une position
en ce sens le peuple n'a pas à donner
son avis sur les affaires fiscales le
sujet des super profits que des
ministres ont essayé de décrédibiliser
au départ plutôt que de se voir affublé
une nouvelle étiquette de défenseur des
riches du patronat etc dans un second
temps la tentative d'une faiblesse
incomparable a consisté à décrédibiliser
les recettes qui en seraient tirées au
motif que les entreprises ne payent pas
d'impôts sur les bénéfices en France
repris à la cantonade dans les médias
nuls ne sont dit que cela constitué ne
se sont dit pardon que cela constitue un
problème primaire voire fondamental que
la réponse à une nouvelle taxation ne
peut être que les entreprises
disposaient déjà de trop de moyens de
contourner l'impôt on l'a dit autant
rendre les clés du ministère des
Finances laisser la place à ceux qui
souhaitent prélever un juste niveau de
richesse enfin le gouvernement arrive
devant nous avec une contribution
exceptionnelle sur les raffineurs et un
plafond sur les rentes des producteurs
d'électricité le premier un dispositif
notoirement insuffisant le deuxième une
usine à gaz permettez-moi l'expression
de noter battrons plus tard le ministre
Bruno Le Maire lançant à cette assemblée
une taxe sur les électriciens une taxe
sur les super profits appelez-la comme
vous voulez les super profits il n'y en
a pas de bons et les mauvais il n'y en a
pas de bon pour certains secteurs ou des
mauvais pour certains entreprises le
mouvement de rang de l'argent pour
l'argent concerne l'ensemble des
secteurs de l'économie
ce n'est pas le cas ils ne seront pas
assujettis cessons une bataille
sémantique qui consiste à éviter pour
les gouvernements de masquer qu'il a
toujours su ce qu'était les super
profits et qu'il refuse d'aller les
chercher merci le 17 mai
merci madame la Présidente donc
l'amendement du groupe Union centriste
vise à instituer une contribution
exceptionnelle de solidarité sur les
supers profits tous secteurs d'activités
confondues les entreprises dont le
bénéfice net auraient été en 2022
supérieur à 10 millions d'euros et
supérieur de 20% à la moyenne des 3
bénéfices nets les plus élevés réalisés
au cours des quatre années
2018-2019-2020-2021 se verrait appliquer
une contribution en hauteur de 33%
calculer sur la différence entre les
deux montants alors monsieur le ministre
en août lors du PLFR 2 vous même et
Bruno Le Maire est-il opposé à cette
taxation que nous avions proposé au
motif qu'il fallait laisser aux
entreprises la capacité de réussir leur
transition écologique
alors vous parliez pas tellement de
taxation européenne à l'époque pas au
mois d'août en septembre les choses
étaient un peu plus mûres la première
ministre a évoqué la question le
président de la République également et
réflexion faite le gouvernement est mûr
pour une taxation européenne le problème
c'est que ceux qui vont être taxés sont
les énergéticiens précisément ceux qui
ont matière à réussir leur transition
écologique et moi je me demande dans ce
cas est-ce que BNP Paribas a aussi
beaucoup besoin de ces super profits
pour réussir sa transition écologique
j'ai eu du mal à comprendre la cohérence
dans ses arguments il y a deux jours
monsieur le ministre vous dites qu'il ne
faut pas taxer tout le monde et pas ceux
qui ont fait des profits pour d'autres
raisons que la crise énergétique
pourtant Bruno Le Maire a dit lors de la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques qu'il allait se chercher de se
charger d'aller chercher l'argent là où
il est et en premier lieu chez les
gafams voilà alors je ne comprends
toujours pas la cohérence pourquoi
certains sont taxés et pas d'autres
pourquoi les gafams ont pu aller
chercher ces super profits par le reste
des entreprises qui constituent qui font
des super profits en France en avons
voulu ou les moyens non à l'évidence non
notre définition public alimentent
l'inflation et ce n'est pas suffisant
merci Monsieur Bruyer pour le 604
bien nous avons choisi de déposer un
amendement commun avec nos collègues
socialistes et je voudrais rajouter
quelques mots à l'occasion de cet
amendement propre d'abord pour dire que
nous nous félicitons qu'enfin dans notre
hémicycle chacun sache que sont les
super profits puisque c'était encore une
donnée qui paraissait inaccessible
inaccessible incompréhensible et
inintelligible voilà trois mois les
super profits taxés en période de crise
majeure ne sont pas une nouveauté et
l'État a su prendre des mesures de ce
type là de ce type là je ne vous ferai
pas de retour historique jusqu'à
Napoléon où les profiteurs de guerre
mais il n'y a rien d'incongru ce qui est
incongru c'est d'annoncer de telles
super profits dans une période où du
côté du budget de la Nation nous
accumulons des déficits et
j'entends d'ailleurs sur tous les bancs
de la majorité sénatoriale une crainte
sans doute fondée de l'excès de ces
déficits mais en aucun cas la côté
d'aller diminuer ces déficits par la
taxation de gens qui font des profits
non pas parce que ils ont eu le courage
l'intelligence de faire des
investissements de faire des créations
mais parce qu'ils ont profité d'une
situation de crise vous taxez les super
profits des électriciens du des
énergéticiens du renouvelable mais
l'énergie carbonée la pharmacie
transport maritime ou le secteur
bancaire dégage des profits et je
termine juste sur un mot j'ai été élu
d'une commune très populaire franchement
quand on mesure ces super profits et que
les gens sont nombreux à aller à la
banque alimentaire les étudiants qui ont
fait des files d'attente ne comprennent
pas que notre pays puisse se dire on ne
va pas taxer des super profits nous
sommes en déficit nous n'avons pas
toujours les moyens de mener les
politiques sociales qui seraient
nécessaires et que nous appellerions
tous de nos vœux mais nous refusons de
taxer les super profits il y a là
quelque chose d'inacceptable et qui
génère des colères profond des sourdes
et ses colères profondes peuvent mal
tourner et ça nous ne le souhaitons pas
et nous préférons anticiper par cette
taxation des super profits la vie de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur sur
ses amendements
on a eu l'occasion il y a quelques
instants de d'aborder la question des
super dividendes on aborde la question
certains les appellent les super profits
d'autres les profits indus voir des
profits exceptionnels effectivement
chacun met le mot qu'il veut
la situation est aujourd'hui et depuis
quelques temps
ça avait commencé avec différentes
crises d'ailleurs ça a été le temps de
la crise sanitaire
c'est devenu la crise au début de
l'énergie puis des énergies avec enfin
des énergies et la crise
russo-ukrainienne c'est-à-dire non pas
la crise mais la guerre qui n'a fait que
renforcer et je dirais amplifier
dans certains secteurs d'activité la
profitabilité d'entreprise
moi je vais vous dire
trouver le je dirais là juste
appréciation est assez compliqué entre
se dire il y a quelques entreprises et
je viens d'entendre par exemple et je
crois que chacun le voit
réaliser des profits exceptionnels dans
le domaine des énergies ça paraît assez
évident de là à dire toutes celles des
entreprises qui alors là c'est
l'abonnement décentrices
disent au-delà d'un résultat supérieur à
10 millions d'euros avec un calcul qui a
rappelé la sénatrice il vivait
vermeiller et sur une certaine durée
toutes celles des entreprises qui
seraient concernés et bien
elle passe à la caisse je trouve que
c'est un peu dur
de la prendre sur une période qui couvre
si j'ai compris qui peut couvrir 5 ans
c'est à dire vous êtes une entreprise en
croissance et tout à coup il y a une
intervention ensuite qui est on va se le
dire qui n'est pas lié à la situation de
2018 ou 19 qui est lié à la crise
sanitaire au début je le redis et aux
crises énergétiques et liée au conflit
ruisseau ukrainien je trouve
personnellement que cette excessif et
que ça n'est pas juste en tous les cas
pour certaines entreprises deuxième
élément et vous le savez il y a des
entreprises qui
ont comment dirais-je un rayonnement
international vous connaissez les règles
parce que c'est le je dirais le
dispositif est suffisamment connu de
chacun d'entre nous où il y a des
profitabilités donc des profits toujours
très élevés exceptionnel mais qui ne
permettent pas pas regarder règles de
venir pour la France chercher ce qu'on
identifie comme des profits
exceptionnels quand bien même ce sont
des entreprises dont personnellement
mais je pense sincèrement d'entre nous
sont d'organisme de voir à la tête le
drapeau de la France sur des
multinationales je préfère aussi avoir
des grandes entreprises qui rayonnent
dans le monde et dont les temps d'art et
notre drapeau tricolore avec un grand
nombre d'emplois plutôt que d'être à la
remorque ou moquer ou railler alors vous
allez me dire l'un n'empêche pas l'autre
n'est pas l'ennemi de l'autre mais ça
doit aussi être mis dans le débat public
voilà c'est autant d'éléments et il
reste derrière la question vous l'avez
évoqué moi je ça ne me gêne pas d'en
reparler entre ces profits c'est oui
c'est bénéfice exceptionnel et puis
les dividendes ou les rémunérations des
chefs d'entreprise puisqu'on l'a vu
également plutôt
oui on peut congérer que c'est choquant
si je le dis moi à titre personnel je
trouve qu'on a l'impression que
l'écart-type un peu comme un chewing-gum
sallonge inexorablement c'est un peu
comme la valse des milliards quand on
réfléchit on se dit mais c'est pas
possible comment des personnes qui ont
forcément du talent pour être à la tête
des entreprises touchent perçoivent de
telles rémunération
et
concomitamment on observe que si c'est
celle d'entreprise et on l'a vu
d'ailleurs n'était pas
ou ne sont pas toujours d'ailleurs
français mais on va chercher les
meilleurs parce qu'on pense que enfin
les entreprises qui choisissent vont
chercher les meilleurs pour
réussir à entretenir la dynamique de
l'entreprise et chercher des bons
résultats ben évidemment je suis un peu
comme vous
en regardant ce qui se passe dans le
monde du sport ou c'est pas au départ
celle ou ceux dont on pensait qu'ils
allaient avoir le plus de talent mais il
y a le travail qui est là derrière et
qui amène des rémunérations et des
résultats
parfois tout à fait exceptionnel je le
dis qui me donne aussi le vertige est-ce
que pour autant il faut aller taxer je
le redis temporairement et
à cette ou assez auteur
oui auteur je n'en suis pas
personnellement convaincu je crois que
certes il faut regarder
sereinement et avec un esprit critique
mais il faut aussi regarder de quelle
manière ces entreprises se comportent
dans le je dirais le fonctionnement
habituel c'est certes la profitabilité
mais peut-être aussi leur politique de
développement de rayonnement de plus en
plus et je l'espère toutes les démarches
RSE et l'engagement qui peut être le
leurre dans la transition écologique
économique environnementale et
j'ajouterai social parce que ainsi nous
avons quelque part le trépied qui est
celui du développement durable mais
surtout d'une croissance qui pour ces
entreprises doit servir le rayonnement
du pays et l'emploi des citoyens ou
qu'ils soient en France et à travers le
monde
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre la vie du gouvernement
merci madame le Président de beaucoup a
été dit par le rapporteur général et on
a commencé à avoir une partie du débat
sur les amendements sur les dividendes
moi je veux dire qu'on a à se réjouir
que on est plus trouver au niveau
européen un mécanisme permettant de
faire contribuer les secteurs qui
profitent de la situation d'inflation
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui c'est à dire
les secteurs de l'énergie on fait on met
à contribution des secteurs qui du fait
de la spéculation ou du fait de la
raréfaction d'un certain nombre de
ressources bénéficient de profits que
nous considérons indus puisqu'ils sont
immédiatement liés à cette situation
c'est le cas des énergéticiens et donc
la contribution telle que portée dans le
PLF tel camed je l'espère à l'issue du
débat que nous aurons ce soir permettra
de rapporter 11 milliards d'euros ce qui
est proposé ici c'est de mettre en place
une taxe une super taxe sur des
entreprises qui ont vu leur situation
une progression importante par rapport
aux dernières années et qui ont alors il
y a différents critères selon les
amendements mais pour l'amendement UC un
bénéfice supérieur à 10 millions d'euros
ce qui est important et ce qui en même
temps et le cas de beaucoup
d'entreprises y compris des entreprises
de taille intermédiaires moi je le redis
ce qui me dérange avec cette proposition
c'est que elle va venir surtaxer des
entreprises qui ont fait des profits
mais qui n'ont rien à voir avec la crise
actuelle qui ont fait des profits parce
qu'elles ont investi qui ont fait des
profits parce que un dirigeant est
arrivé à la tête de l'entreprise et il a
redressé la boîte qui ont vu leurs
résultats s'améliorer parce qu'elles ont
fait elles ont été déficitaires au
moment du covid et que leur situation
s'améliore en sortie de covid donc je
comprends pas pourquoi aller les
pénaliser elle alors que ça n'est pas
lié à l'inflation elle ne profite pas
entre guillemets la situation
d'inflation sur les prix de l'énergie et
c'est ça la réponse que je voulais vous
apporter madame Vermeillet pourquoi
est-ce que nous taxons et nous mettons à
contribution le secteur de énergie
encore une fois parce qu'il bénéficie
d'une forme de rente de situation du
fait de la guerre en Ukraine qui
raréfient des ressources en énergie et
du fait d'une forme de spéculation qui a
lieu notamment dans le secteur du gaz
c'est pour ça vous avez parlé des gafam
on a été un des premiers pays à mettre
en place une taxe sur les Gafa elle
rapportera l'an prochain 700 millions
d'euros donc on n'a pas de problème à
aller chercher les profits je rappelle
que la France est quand même toujours le
deuxième pays qui taxe le plus dans le
CDE on est deuxième derrière le Danemark
donc on a pas de problème avec les
impôts en termes de principes donc moi
je redis que votre supertax elle
taxerait des entreprises qui n'ont pas
profité spécialement de la situation
telle que l'on la connaît aujourd'hui
mais qui se sont redressés pour x ou y
raison parfois parce qu'elles ont été
déficitaires ces dernières années
parfois à cause du covid s'attaque
serait à des entreprises comme Peugeot
stelantis Airbus
face à la crise qu'a connue le secteur
de l'aérien face aux enjeux qu'à le
secteur de l'aérien a investir dans la
recherche et développement pour l'avion
bas carbone pour l'avion à hydrogène
pour réduire l'empreinte carbone de
l'aviation Airbus taxé Air Liquide
Saint-Gobain et des entreprises de
taille intermédiaire des ETI encore une
fois qui ont pu connaître des
difficultés pendant le covid et à ce
titre être déficitaire qui ont connu une
amélioration mais qui ne doivent pas à
mon sens être pénalisés à ce titre c'est
un vrai débat que nous avons et donc je
donne un avis défavorable à vos
amendements
merci beaucoup alors monsieur le
Président rappin
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre on va faire un petit jeu de
rôle
je suis chef d'entreprise et quel que
soit les montants qui ont été évoqués au
travers les bancs ce n'est pas une taxe
que j'aurais l'impression qu'on me
demande ce n'est pas non plus une
contribution mais j'aurai l'impression
de payer une amende une amende sur la
réussite
une amende sur
des gains dont le ministre a dit
qu'effectivement il pouvait venir de
fait tout à fait différent de la crise
qu'on a vécue mais simplement par une
croissance de l'entreprise parce que on
a ciblé un élément du marché qui était
important et je vais citer un cas je
sais qu'il va toucher pas mal de
personnes ici puisque c'est celui du
maritime dans le transport maritime 90%
des produits manufacturés circulent par
la mer c'est un macgm a fait des profits
importants pourquoi des profits
importants parce que
l'offre est plus et plus importante et
moins importante que la demande
et donc sur le marché peu d'entreprises
peuvent assurer cette fonction de
transport maritime
rodols Saad au cours d'une d'une
audition ici au Sénat a expliqué qu'il
m'était en place un fond vert un
milliard et demi pour transformer ces
navires pour aller dans le sens de ce
qu'on demande tous ici la transformation
écologique
de tous les matériaux circulants
un milliard et demi c'est le fond vert
national qui va être mis en place cette
année rendez-vous compte donc
l'entreprise prend sur ses profits du
profits ces bénéfices pour créer un fond
vert je trouve ça important on se plaint
ici souvent dans cette hémicycle madame
la Présidente vous allez me regarder de
travers on se plaint ici dans cette
hémicycle du rayonnement de la France et
du manque de rayonnement de la France au
travail à l'international que de mieux
que c'est pavillons français ces belles
entreprises qui nous permettent
aujourd'hui d'avoir ce rayonnement
français au travers justement les
profits qu'ils gagnent et je me permets
monsieur le ministre n'oubliez pas quand
vous parlez de l'investissement
industriel en France de l'action des
régions l'action des régions et les
investissements des régions c'est
important de le signe de
merci Monsieur Cozic
merci madame la Présidente
quelques mots au nom de le groupe
socialiste va voter l'ensemble des
amendements qui sont présentés et
notamment suit présenté par le groupe
centriste et d'ailleurs je note avec
beaucoup de courage la constance qui
vous anime cher collègue vous aviez fait
cette proposition lors du PLFR cet été
et vous continuez donc je vous maintenez
votre votre amendement je vous en
remercie je voulais monsieur le ministre
je voulais aussi rebondir sur ce que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure sur les
supers dividendes en disant que ça
posait un problème de constitutionnalité
par rapport à l'impôt je pense que la
taxe sur les super profits résout en
grande partie cette difficulté
je vais pas répéter ce qui a été dit
j'aurais quand même rebondir sur le sur
la construction européenne notamment sur
l'Europe et je note que plus que jamais
ces construction européenne et
salvatrice pour notre pays dans ces
temps troublés cette grande Europe
monsieur le ministre vous lui devez
beaucoup c'est grâce à elle que le
ministre de l'Économie a pu découvrir et
comprendre ce qui était un super profit
sans l'intervention européenne il
déclarait ne pas savoir ce qui était un
super profit
je suis heureux de noter que l'Europe
lui a permis d'y voir plus clair sur le
sujet
c'est encore et toujours grâce à cette
grande Europe que l'idée d'une taxation
de ces super profits en fin défini vous
est apparu acceptable je tiens donc à
remercier l'Europe qui a mis fin à votre
cécité
sur ce sujet
d'ailleurs je note qu'il est quand même
très regrettable que sur ces sujets qui
sont pourtant structurants pour notre
société la voie de la France soit
cantonnée à celle de simples caisses
d'enregistrement de décision
supranationale pour lesquelles vous êtes
originalement opposé donc accepter cette
proposition de taxation c'est enfin je
pense être force de proposition et non
plus être un éternel suivi
perpétuellement à rebours de l'époque
merci monsieur le président de La Haye
la présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues au mois d'août dernier
effectivement nous étions déçus que
notre proposition ne puisse pas aboutir
depuis on a été content de voir que
l'Europe s'est inspiré de notre
amendement puisque à l'époque non mais
regardez la chronologie monsieur le
Président la chronologie quand on a
déposé notre amendement au mois d'août
c'était une contribution exceptionnelle
de solidarité ce terme a été repris par
l'Union européenne j'entends que le
ministre la reprend aussi à son compte
très bien le mode de calcul est super
profit il était dans notre amendement la
moyenne et les 20% au-dessus de la
moyenne c'était notre amendement donc ça
a été repris tant mieux on est content
et je pense qu'il commence à avoir un
consensus là-dessus alors après est-ce
que c'est bien ce que c'est pas bien
la question nous n'est pas on n'est pas
très favorable à l'impôt d'une façon
générale en tout cas au niveau de la
peau auquel on est arrivé mais c'est lié
à la dépense publique en France et on a
connu des années de crise on continue à
connaître des aides on a maintenu le
pouvoir d'achat à crédit en dépensant
des centaines de milliards d'euros on a
maintenu l'activité à crédit et il y a
beaucoup d'acteurs qui en ont bénéficié
d'une façon directe ou indirecte tant
mieux pour eux et tant mieux pour elle
mais aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on dit on
a dépensé à tout va et avec le quoi
qu'il en coûte aujourd'hui on se dit
ceux qui ont bien vécu pendant cette
période là il y a pas de raison qu'il ne
participent pas à un petit peu on
demande pas non plus on confisque pas
tout ce qui est au-dessus de 20% on
demande une participation à l'effort
national qui a été réalisé pendant cette
période là donc on est je pense que
c'est une question de justice vis-à-vis
de l'ensemble de nos concitoyens on leur
dit que la situation est difficile
qu'elle va être encore plus difficile
moi je crains qu'elle soit encore plus
difficile à un moment donné il faut que
tout le monde participe et que ceux qui
ont bien vécu comme je l'ai dit puisse
apporter leur au bol et c'est ce qu'on
demande avec notre amendement merci
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre chez un collègue je crois
que personne ne peut taxer les centrices
de ne pas aimer l'entreprise de la même
façon de la même façon nous voulons
aider l'aérien comme nous voulons aider
le maritime nous en sommes bien
conscients et ces sociétés ont besoin de
l'aide de l'État et d'investissement
pour des grands projets dans même nous
les ultramarins nous avons besoin ceci
dit je crois que quand on fait de la
politique le symbole compte il n'y a pas
de politique sans symbole
on ne reviendra pas à la nuit du 4 août
mais tout simplement à côté des
ministres pour une langouste trop rouge
ou trop importante ben il y en a qui qui
saute au niveau politique pourquoi parce
que nous sommes dans des symboles et ce
ne sont pas des parlementaires comme
vous qui connaissez bien mieux que moi
une petite nouvelle arrivante ici qui
connaît la vie politique et ses tumuls
qui dira que le parole ne compte pas en
politique de la même façon la vie
culturelle le symbole compte et quand
Notre Dame de Paris brûle et bien
évidemment ce symbole là doit être
défendu et des fonds d'investissement
d'aide qu'il s'agisse de priver ou des
aides de l'État est important pour le
plus grand nombre de citoyens parce
qu'ils ont besoin de lire la politique
et nous sommes les représentants du
peuple ici et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
dans la période de crise que nous
connaissons il est mal venu de ne pas
parler d'une solidarité contributive de
la part de ceux qui gagnent et qui ont
gagné beaucoup d'argent ça ne veut pas
dire du tout que les parlementaires que
nous sommes ou que le gouvernement soit
contre les entreprises ou contre le fait
de gagner de l'argent au contraire moi
je suis toujours très contente de voir
briller et retrouver des entreprises
françaises quand il m'arrive de voyager
à travers
pays que le nôtre et donc voilà pourquoi
je défendrai les amendements qui ont été
portés
le peuple en tous les cas ne comprendrez
absolument pas que les inégalités
continuent à se
creuser entre les plus bas et ce qu'on
appelle les monsieur dessus
merci madame la Présidente mais moi je
voulais réagir au discours du ministre
qui emballe avec sa doxa habituelle un
centre de contre-vérité les périodes que
vous nous disent ça peut attaquer des
entreprises qui se remettent de la
période covid mais l'amendement qu'on a
déposé exclut la période covid on parle
d'un chiffre d'affaires sur les trois
années précédentes donc ce n'est pas
vrai quand vous parlez de l'entreprise
de taille quasi moyenne vous nous avez
dit on parle d'entreprises qui font un
chiffre d'affaires de au-delà de 750
millions d'euros c'est quand même nous
sommes conséquente on nous dites des
entreprises qui ont investi qui veulent
récupérer leur investissement on parle
de Sanofi qui n'a même pas réussi à
trouver un vaccin pendant la période qui
a licencié 1700 personnes en R&D dont
1000 en France et qui a quand même fait
338% de profit donc c'est ça le génie
français qu'on récupère qu'on récompense
je ne comprends pas alors moi sur le sur
l'exemple de CM1
CMA ils font des supers profits parce
qu'ils ont les bateaux les
infrastructures ils sont là au bon
moment au bon endroit quand l'économie
redémarre mais en fait c'est parce que
l'économie a été en panne pendant deux
ans que forcément il y a une demande qui
a explosé et donc c'est comme ça qui
justifie leur super profit et bon sur
les énergéticiens vous y êtes arrivé
quand même vous avez compris qu'il y
avait des énergéticiens qui saignaient
tout le monde et donc il fallait
récupérer de l'argent le si le flow vous
me dites il faut être fier du drapeau
français au dessus des au frontons des
grandes entreprises mais excusez moi je
ne suis pas fier l'activité totale qui
continue ses activités avec un criminel
de guerre et qui continue de vouloir
saloper l'Ouganda avec ses projets
d'exploitation voilà
si Monsieur Dominati
oui monsieur le ministre madame la
Présidente malgré les nombreux
explications moi je n'ai toujours pas
vraiment bien compris ce qui était les
super profit je suis compris que c'était
une période de 4 ans que s'il y en avait
un résultat exceptionnel sur cette
moyenne de 4 ans on a été taxé ce qui
est le cas de la SNCF ce qui est le cas
par exemple des agriculteurs avec le
prix du blé 160 euros la tonne 210 euros
la tonne aujourd'hui autrement dit c'est
un impôt ou une contribution
exceptionnelle conjoncturelle elle peut
frapper n'importe qui n'importe quand
n'importe quel territoire on pourrait le
faire sur le site des Jeux Olympiques
par exemple parce que ça sera une
contribution ou des profits
exceptionnels on pourrait le faire sur
des phases cycliques par exemple notre
armée doit se réinvestir faire quelques
achats importants contenus de la
conjoncture internationale donc
probablement que notre industrie va
faire des super profits euh dans les
deux années qui viennent je n'arrive
toujours pas à comprendre moi ce que je
comprends simplement c'est qu'on parle
souvent de stabilité fiscale et une
stabilité fiscale nécessaire à la
croissance au développement et à la
compétitivité et là en fonction d'une
conjoncture on va dire simplement là on
va faire des supers profits alors
puisqu'on en est au symbole et puis j'ai
entendu mon collègue Vincent Delahaye
disjon elles ont bien vécu donc il faut
payer alors il faut mal vivre pour ne
pas payer je trouve que le concept est
pour le moins curieux alors si on en est
au symbole monsieur le ministre moi je
voudrais savoir si on pourrait pas faire
une taxe sur les entreprises qui n'ont
pas fait super profit parce qu'il y en a
qui auraient dû le faire par exemple
dans l'énergie on parle d'EDF
normalement chez EDF avait été une
entreprise au rendez-vous et à l'heure
elle aurait dû faire des super profits
comme la SNCF parce que la SNCF elle a
fait des super profits au cours de
l'année 2021 puisqu'elle dégage 3
milliards elle avait perdu 3 milliards
d'années précédentes elle avait perdu
300 millions l'année précédente donc
peut-être quelques symboles il faudrait
trouver un taxer ceux qui ne font pas
bien leur boulot aussi merci monsieur le
Président Marseille
le ministre mes chers collègues moi j'ai
écouté effectivement les échanges que
nous avons eu et notamment aussi tous
ceux que nous avons eu au moment du PLF
j'ai entendu beaucoup d'arguments
concernant des sujets techniques
relatifs à cette contribution qui qui
est demandé aux entreprises le problème
il est pas technique peut parler d'un
certain nombre d'années on peut parler
d'un taux on peut parler de tout ce
qu'on veut le problème il est politique
problème il est politique est-ce que on
considère qui a des profits
exceptionnels à un moment donné oui
puisque on les taxe même au niveau
européen donc qui soit nationaux ou
européen c'est qu'on les reconnaît
mais on préfère se planquer derrière les
Allemands derrière les autres qui eux
qui eux dès le mois de juillet ont
organisé des contributions nationales
les Espagnols les Italiens de Monsieur
Draghi Boris Johnson en Angleterre à ma
connaissance c'est pas des marxistes les
ministres bon ils ont organisé ça des
mois de juillet donc le problème est de
savoir si on laisse faire et on dit
c'est les entreprises qui décident la
fiscalité c'est plus la faire de l'État
la redistribution c'est plus l'affaire
de l'État on laisse faire les
entreprises pourquoi pas moi j'entends
et à ce moment-là on dit c'est vous qui
vous organisez c'est d'ailleurs ce que
j'entendais au mois de juillet pour le
pouvoir d'achat le seul pouvoir d'achat
qui a véritablement augmenté c'est celui
de Monsieur pouyané si j'ai bien compris
et également celui de Monsieur Tavares
et c'était dentiste qui a pris un petit
bonus de 66 millions il y a un problème
d'exemplarités comme l'a dit ma collègue
madame problème c'est pas le rapport
que ça rapporte beaucoup un peu ou pas
du tout à la limite là aussi le problème
il est politique est-ce qu'il y a une
symbolique on dit c'est l'État qui
décide c'est lui qui organise la
fiscalité c'est lui qui organise la
redistribution et il y a une
contribution c'est normal elle est
exceptionnelle et il y a une symbolique
à partir du moment où on dit bah
qu'est-ce que vous voulez avant y gagner
pas ou il gagne plus ou il gagne bien et
c'est normal etc pourquoi pas mais alors
après faut que ça serve de référence
parce que maintenant on a un vrai sujet
si on commence à expliquer que c'est les
entreprises qui décident de ce qu'elle
doit faire avec les profits un moment ou
un autre
on verra pour l'avenir comment ça se
passe merci Monsieur Sautarel
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues moi je
voulais revenir à une dimension un tout
petit peu plus pragmatique un peu moins
idéologique et je voulais faire
référence à deux aspects d'abord la
dimension européenne ce que je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas aborder ce
genre de questions sans le faire dans un
cadre européen et force est de constater
si nous si nous n'avons pas pu prendre
au niveau national les mêmes mesures que
d'autres États c'est parce que déjà
comme la rappeler d'ailleurs monsieur le
ministre nos taux de prélèvement sont
déjà substantiellement plus élevés que
la moyenne européenne et donc de ce
point de vue là moi je me réjouis qu'on
ait pu mettre en place à l'échelle
européenne une taxe les énergéticiens
qui s'appliquent sur l'ensemble du
territoire européen et qui va ramener le
ministre la rappeler également plus de
11 milliards d'euros dans les caisses de
l'État et je souhaiterais d'ailleurs
qu'à ce titre là à l'échelle européenne
on peut savoir d'autres approches
pragmatiques c'est pas le sujet du débat
mais j'y reviendrai dans un autre cadre
je veux juste le rappeler là si nous
arrivions à avancer le prix de l'énergie
et en particulier pour avoir pour la
France le tarif ibérique ça nous
rendrait bien service et ça nous préfère
bien des économies budgétaires ça
c'était ma première remarque pragmatique
la deuxième Philippe dominatile l'a
évoqué mais je voulais insister sur la
SNCF il s'avère que en tant que
commissaire au transport ou rapporteur
spécial au transport nous avons
auditionné le président farandou et
effectivement sur une mesure telle que
celle qui est proposée sans rentrer dans
le détail la SNCF et sa filiale Geodis
qui a fait de grands profits au cours de
ces dernières années autant que CGS
c'est
assezm pardon qui a rayonné au niveau de
la logistique à l'échelle mondiale
serait taxé très fortement et au-delà de
cette filiale Geodis sur cet exercice
2021 la SNCF qui a fait des profits
exceptionnels cette année dont on espère
qu'elle pourra réinvestir parce que on a
bien besoin d'investir dans nos réseaux
et donc de ce point de vue là je
préférerais qu'elle puisse réinvestir
plutôt que de contribuer à un effort
national dont on ne sait pas ce qu'il
serait ensuite sur le budgétaire voilà
je voulais juste faire ces deux
remarques pragmatiques merci Monsieur
Delcros
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre
hier à l'occasion de d'un amendement que
défendait notre groupe de l'Union
centriste vous nous avez invité j'ai
envie de dire d'ailleurs à juste titre à
faire extrêmement attention au message
qu'on a envoyé aux Français à un moment
autant de ménage se trouvait dans la
situation difficile et j'ai envie de
vous retourner cet argument tout à fait
justifié nous nous y trompons pas à
travers cette contribution
exceptionnelle sur les super propices
qui au-delà de l'intérêt qu'elle a parce
qu'on crée une recette exceptionnelle
pour faire face à des dépenses
exceptionnelles que vous avez engagées
pour protéger les Français et que nous
soutenons
cette contribution a été espionnelle sur
les super profits c'est un message
envoyé aux Français
et refuser cette contribution
exceptionnelle sur le super profit c'est
un de notre point de vue c'est un
mauvais message envoyé aux Français dans
la situation actuelle je voulais vous
rappeler cette chose là puisque nous
avons l'occasion de l'évoquer hier
merci Monsieur Ferro
merci madame la Présidente quand même
dans ce débat pas mal d'arguments qui
sont faux
d'abord ça toucherait tout le monde cher
philippe Dominati 750 millions d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires ça n'est pas
toutes les entreprises ce ne sont pas
les agriculteurs suite monsieur ministre
vous dites l'attractivité de la France
est très grande grâce à une trajectoire
de baisse d'impôts importantes et puis
vous dites également que nous avons les
deuxièmes fiscalités la plus élevée ce
qui montre d'ailleurs qu'elle n'empêche
pas notre attractivité très grande aimer
l'entreprise ou pas aimer l'entreprise
c'est Claude rénal tout à l'heure le
président de la commission des finances
qui rappelait que la trajectoire de
baisse de l'IS a commencé sous le
quinquennat de François Hollande donc si
c'est un référentiel pour l'amour de
l'entreprise les socialistes aiment
l'entreprise la réalité c'est que
l'ensemble de ceux qui refusent cette
taxation des super profits
sont un peu sur la défensive le
gouvernement vu rapporteur général il y
a beaucoup d'arguments du rapporteur
général qui aurait pu conduire à mettre
en place un mécanisme de taxation même
modeste même symbolique puis il y a
aussi les entreprises finalement c'est
sous la pression de ce débat que CGM cm
CM1 met en place un fond vert et puis
pendant que
Eric Bocquet lisait les échos moi j'ai
regardé LCI et j'ai vu que Patrick
pouillanet disait à LCI cette année
totale énergie va payer l'impôt sur les
sociétés en France ça nous évitera une
nouvelle polémique et bien la polémique
au moins aura été utile j'espère que
nous allons voter l'un de nos
amendements mais même si nous ne le
votons pas je crois que nous aurons fait
oeuvres utile avec ce débat sur la mise
à contribution des super profits et ça
n'est pas une amende les impôts sont une
contribution à l'intérêt général
merci Monsieur Canivet
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues quelques
convictions peut-être qui animent le
groupe de l'Union centriste c'est tout
d'abord effectivement comme cela a été
dit tout à l'heure par Thierry Cozic de
la constance nous souhaitons être
constant
lorsque
la situation est devenue difficile dans
notre pays je veux parler de la pandémie
tout le monde s'est retourné vers l'état
nous les premiers pour dire qu'il
fallait absolument aider l'ensemble des
acteurs économiques et nos concitoyens
et on a trouvé effectivement le
gouvernement qui a répondu comme
récemment quand la crise de l'énergie et
la guerre entraîné un surco sur
l'énergie on sait légitimement ainsi
retourné vers le gouvernement et
on a obtenu donc un certain nombre de
mesures d'accompagnement pour les
entreprises et pour les particuliers
donc on voit bien qu'il est légitime
qu'en contrepartie nous nous
préoccupions aussi de d'accompagner ceux
qui sont les plus en difficulté de
solliciter ceux qui profite de la
situation alors ce que l'on dit
simplement c'est quand demande aux
entreprises qui en fait plus de 10
millions d'euros de bénéfices et dont le
bénéfice la moyenne de bénéfices sur les
quatre dernières années et supérieure de
20% à celle aux bénéfice de 2022
d'apporter une petite contribution qui
n'est qu'une part de leur bénéfice il
s'agit pas de tout prendre pour la
solidarité nationale parce que au niveau
de groupe de l'Union centrée nous avons
aussi la conviction que ça ne peut pas
toujours être dans le même sens on ne
peut pas se contenter d'engager des
dépenses pour l'État il faut également
qu'on se préoccupe des recettes et nous
souhaitons pour notre part que le
déficit soit le plus réduit possible et
ça veut dire que très concrètement
lorsque d'un côté on dépense il faut
qu'il y ait des recettes en contrepartie
et la situation exceptionnelle
contribution exceptionnelle il n'y a
absolument rien d'anormal à ce sujet
donc soyons conscient que il faut
absolument que tout le monde participe
c'est une question de solidarité
vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens qui sont
les plus en difficulté et qui
quelques éléments rapides 3 première
chose d'abord bien évidemment le
dividende n'est pas l'ennemi l'actionné
un n'est pas l'ennemi il faut rémunérer
l'actionnaire qui investit et qui est à
risque lorsqu'il le fait nous sommes je
crois d'accord là-dessus deuxième chose
il n'y a pas que le secteur de l'énergie
qui a quand même fait des profits
importants dans cette période là donc la
question n'est pas illégitime de dire on
peut regarder
en situation de crise comment se
répartit le coût de la crise cette crise
cette crise énergétique cette crise
d'approvisionnement cette crise dit au
covid etc tout ça a un coup de pour
l'économie et il y a pas de 36 solutions
qui paye ce coûte c'est l'état alors
l'état ça va te dire de la dette et ça
veut dire qu'on transfère la charge de
la crise aux générations futures
ça peut être les ménages les ménages le
paient de deux façons en pouvoir d'achat
ou bien ils vont le payer en impôt si on
gère pas bien nos finances et ça peut
nous arriver demain matin s'il est tôt
monte trop vite et si les marchés
s'affolent et là on n'aura pas le choix
donc il faut se poser la question l'État
c'est les générations futures les
ménages c'est le pouvoir d'achat et
c'est les impôts et bien on pose aussi
la question en lisant les entreprises
pour une part tout à l'heure on a eu le
débat sur le cier il faut pas y toucher
les impôts de production faut aussi les
baisser évidemment ok on croit ouverture
des baisses impôts mais simplement quand
on est dans une situation économiques où
il faut trouver des recettes nous posons
juste la question de dire comment on
répartit cette recherche de recettes il
faut couper dans des dépenses il faut
aussi peut-être se poser la question de
mesure on peut discuter celle-ci on peut
trouver que les modalités sont pas les
bonnes mais rejeter le principe en
disant jamais les entreprises là il y a
un problème
dans ce cas là on va dire c'est l'état
la dette et c'est les ménages il faut
trouver une voie autour de tout ça et ça
peut être comme très bien dit
nassimanada des symboles aussi de
montrer qu'il y a une répartition de
l'effort c'est ça qui nous faut me
semble-t-il essayer de trouver
Monsieur Seguin
merci madame la Présidente je comprends
vraiment pas le message que l'on veut
passer vous avez tendance à ignorer
qu'on a une balance commerciale négative
qui s'effondre d'aller en année et là la
seule réponse c'est mettre de la
taxation supplémentaire parce que
quelques entreprises à tout à l'heure on
a évoqué total qui paye de l'impôt en
France mais alors
tout n'a pas été dit dans la réalité il
paye de l'impôt en France simplement
parce que les raffineries avec le la
hausse du prix du carburant les
raffineries sont devenus rentables
donc c'est bien de d'avoir la vérité de
l'ensemble des paramètres donc quel est
le message on veut faire passer un impôt
supplémentaire quand on gagne de
l'argent en France c'est ça vous voulez
vous voulez que le siège social ni plus
ni moins de Total partent à l'étranger
parce qu'on aura toujours autant besoin
des carburants et là on aura plus de
retour du tout sur la taxation et rien
c'est ça le message qu'on veut passer on
a le record absolu du pré aimant
obligatoire sur les entreprises vous
voulez je moi d'après tout ce que vous
dites et surtout l'Union centriste c'est
là que j'arrive pas à comprendre c'est
le message que vous dites c'est que on
veut garder on est le premier pays à
prélever de l'impôt en France on veut
surtout garder cette ce niveau là
c'est ça mais mais continuons continuons
la balance commerciale et à moins 200
milliards mais continuons on va droit à
la catastrophe franchement c'est un
mauvais message pour les entreprises et
les entrepreneurs
merci monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente je vais
essayer d'aller vite je vais d'abord
répondre à Monsieur Ferro et son
collègue du groupe socialiste qui nous
ont reproché à moi-même et à d'autres
intervenants de mentir de mensonges
parce qu'on ne mentionnait pas le fait
qu'il y a un seuil minimum de 750
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
j'ai commencé mon intervention en disant
qu'il y avait plusieurs amendements et
plusieurs critères pardon de répondre
aux amendements qui viennent également
des autres groupes désolé de ne pas me
concentrer uniquement sur le groupe
socialiste je pense que tous les
amendements sont dignes d'intérêt et
c'est normal évidemment que je réponde
aux amendements du groupe UC aux autres
amendements c'est voilà je réponds à
tous les amendements et donc je parle
aussi des amendements qui ne sont pas
les amendements socialistes mais puisque
vous portez poser la question sur votre
amendement il a un gros problème que
l'amendement UC n'a pas pour le coup
c'est que là où l'amendement
UC a quelque chose en plus par rapport à
vous je parle le sens positif du terme
c'est qu'il vient en déduction de la
contribution européenne
là où vous c'est double dose donc ça
veut dire que EDF que engie il se
retrouve tapé deux fois un par la
contribution européenne que le
gouvernement transcrit dans le PLF deux
par votre amendement au moins j'ai envie
de dire à côté UC il y a eu cette
complémentarité entre les deux taxes
donc voilà vous voyez je réponds à votre
amendement je réponds à votre amendement
qui a aussi qui est aussi hautement
hautement problématique
non certainement pas
je vais je voulais maintenant répondre à
Monsieur Marseille vous avez mentionné
vous avez fait un benchmark
international moi je veux dire que les
Allemands ils ont parlé cet été de faire
effectivement une contribution
européenne sur beaucoup de secteurs ça a
été mentionné ils n'ont pas fait la
coalition dans la coalition ça n'a pas
été retenu le Royaume-Uni a fait une
taxe exceptionnelle sur l'extraction de
pétrole ils extraient du pétrole nous on
n'a pas de pétrole on a des idées de
taxes et on n'a pas de de pétrole
l'Italie a annoncé une surtaxe sur les
entreprises à partir d'un certain niveau
de chiffre d'affaires il y a des
contentieux dans tous les sens ça ne
rapporte rien et la nouvelle présidente
du conseil madame Meloni vient
d'annoncer qu'elle retirait la taxe et
qu'ils allaient repartir de zéro
l'Espagne a mis en place une
contribution exceptionnelle notamment
sur les énergéticiens il y a les banques
aussi effectivement ce qui n'est pas le
cas ailleurs mais sur les énergéticiens
qui ressemble grosso modo à la
contribution européenne qui a été décidé
et que l'on transcrit donc je pense que
tout le monde a cherché finalement une
solution pour mettre à contribution de
manière juste des secteurs ou des
entreprises qui ont fait des profits et
je pense que tout le monde s'est posé la
question de quel secteur quelles
entreprises aller mettre à contribution
moi je redis que celles qui ont fait des
profits parce qu'il y a de la
spectaculation de la spéculation sur le
secteur de l'énergie oui il est justifié
d'aller chercher cette cette rente de
situations et c'est ce que nous faisons
avec le mécanisme européen à 11
milliards d'euros je voulais répondre à
Monsieur Dominati qui a demandé sur la
mise à contribution d'EDF moi je veux
dire un que EDF a été mis à contribution
puisque avec le mécanisme de la reine
nous avons relevé c'est une forme de
taxation sur EDF et donc l'entreprise
évidemment était mise à contribution je
voulais enfin terminer en répondant à
Monsieur Delcros oui c'est vrai que les
messages sont importants et c'est vrai
qu'hier sur un certain amendement
c'était celui sur les châteaux je pense
ou non c'était un autre pardon c'était
j'avais dit que j'avais alerté sur le
message que ça pouvait envoyer et donc
moi je ne souhaite pas que ces
amendement soit adopté ce que je
souhaite en revanche ce que j'espère
c'est comment seront examinés les
amendements sur la contribution
européenne qui rapportera quand même 11
milliards d'euros des secteurs de
l'énergie on puisse quand même en sortir
avec un message sur tous les bancs pour
saluer le fait que par rapport à cet été
c'est quand même un vrai progrès et je
terminerai pour Monsieur Delahaye en
disant que oui d'une certaine mesure on
peut dire que ce mécanisme européen
s'inspire de ce que vous aviez porté cet
été dans le mécanisme ça se rapproche la
vraie différence c'est que nous on veut
mettre à contribution les secteurs qui
se sont indument enrichis du de la crise
sur le secteur de l'énergie là où vous
proposez de le faire pour tous les
secteurs mais je reviens pas sur le
débat de tout à l'heure merci alors je
mets aux voix l'amendement 856 qui a
reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission du gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre
n'est pas adopté sur le 434 et 845
identiques je suis saisie d'une demande
de scrutin public par le groupe
socialiste et je vous rappelle que la
vie de la Commission et du gouvernement
et défavorable il va être procédé
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement le
scrutin est ouvert le scrutin clos
j'ai la du scrutin nombre de votants 343
exprimé 278 pour 97 contre 181 le Sénat
n'a pas adopté
j'ai été saisie d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe socialiste sur
l'amendement numéro 17 je vous rappelle
que la vie de la Commission et du
Gouvernement est défavorable va être
procédé au scrutin public dans une
condition fixée par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert le
scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin nombre de votants
343 exprimer 333 pour 152 contre 181 le
Sénat n'a pas adopté je mets aux voix
l'amendement 604 carrossier en avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopte
passe à l'amendement 816 monsieur
Bocquet
monsieur ça va le délit
merci madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues on vient d'avoir un
débat un autre collègue disait il y a un
problème de décision politique il avait
raison
super profit on sait que ça se dit si le
rapport par référendum donc il y aura
pas de décision populaire possible ça
sera pas décidé par l'assemblée
nationale puisqu'il y aura le 49.3 et ça
sera pas décidé ici parce que les
républicains veulent pas
donc il y a un problème il y a un
problème politique oui oui vous pouvez
tergiverser il y a un problème politique
et l'amendement que je défends pour
notre groupe il intervient dans le même
esprit que les super profits il vient
sur la détermination du bénéfice net et
là on peut aussi avoir un débat assez
fourni parce que un certain nombre
d'entreprises ont eu un bénéfice net
pourquoi parce que le bénéfice net il
est souvent fait est lié à la diminution
de charges financière par l'entreprise
et là on a quand même un gouvernement
entre le premier quinquennat et la suite
qu'a amené un niveau de diminution des
charges financières pour un grand nombre
d'entreprises notamment les grands
groupes de manière exceptionnelle et là
monsieur le ministre c'est pas vous mais
c'est votre collègue il a demandé aux
entreprises bénéficiaires d'argent
public de verser des dividendes elles
n'ont pas écouté votre collègue le maire
a demandé d'accroître le partage de la
valeur dans l'entreprise en augmentant
les rémunérations et plus imminent les
salaires il n'a pas écouté non plus et
enfin dernière résignation de votre
collègue le ministre Lemaire que lorsque
les actionnaires se versent des
dividendes les travailleurs puissent en
bénéficier également c'est la poursuite
de cette fameuse thé du ruissellement
des milliards de divisions pour les uns
et puis quelques centaines d'euros pour
les autres c'est une vision à notre avis
éculée et voilà maintenant qu'on ressort
le dividende salarié étant le profit
pour tous et pas pour quelques-uns enfin
franchement vous voyez le niveau du
débat qu'on a
dans un parlement c'est quand même bien
de parler de l'impôt
on peut pas être dans un lieu où l'impôt
est tout le temps décrié
il y a pas l'argent qui va dans la poche
de l'État et de l'argent qui va dans le
poche des travailleurs il y a seulement
le cas des dividendes de l'argent qui va
au capital et qui échappe et aux
travailleurs aux salariés et à l'état et
ces deux derniers ne font qu'un parce
que les salariés les travailleurs et
l'État c'est qu'une seule chose voilà
donc nous demandons
qu'il y ait non pas une amende ou une
taxation des bénéfices des entreprises
comme vous n'étiez pas là je vous le dis
je ne suis pas fatigué du tout
la ville de la commission c'est le
rapporteur général la vie de la
commission sera
identique à la vie des amendements
précédents puisqu'il s'agit du même
débat même si la proposition qui est
faite par le groupe CRCE et une
alternative un mixte entre les solutions
déjà envisagées auparavant donc un avis
défavorable mais ma vie que le ministre
merci je mets donc au voie l'amendement
qui a reçu un avis défavorable comme sur
du gouvernement qui est pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté